this month the spectator becomes the
first magazine in history to print
10,000 issues and we'd like to celebrate
with you subscribe to The Spectator for
12 weeks for just 12 pounds plus we'll
send you a bottle of commemorative
spectator gin absolutely free go to
spectator code at UK forward slash
celebrate
welcome to a rather unusual spectator
podcast
I am Fraser Nelson editor of The
Spectator and during the lockdown were
asking our writers to read their
articles normally when we print the
magazine it is shared by our subscribers
with their friends and family so you
might get Matthew Paris's : for example
read three or four times for every one
time it's printed this sheering is
rather harder to do during the lockdown
so with us Matthew Parris Toby Young and
Isabel Hartman to read out their
articles for this week's magazine first
is Matthew he's talking about this
strange trend while anybody talking
about the coronavirus basically thinks
that everything is vindicated whatever
it was they thought in the first place
there must be a quote from Shakespeare
for this but so far I haven't found it
it's the way we all of us contrived to
see in cosmic events the evidence the
signs and portents for what we already
believed even before the Cataclysm had
occurred these are the days of miracle
and Wonder sang Paul Simon the way we
look to a distant constellation that's
dying in the corner of the sky these are
the days of miracle and Wonder and don't
cry baby don't cry don't cry somehow
there ever was a plague earthquake flood
or epidemic that was not also a sign
that the human race must mend its ways
according to wisdom we had long
recommended even during less
extraordinary times
one fine day perhaps something
remarkable and strange may happen that
causes us to review even horrors abandon
a dearly held belief but not yet baby
not yet not yet not we have the print
and broadcast commentary at anyway and I
hasten to say this starts with your
columnist at least as guilty as anyone
of my journalistic brethren there was a
sort of inevitability about my take on
the latest emergency you'd have guessed
wouldn't you that you're predictably in
tediously contrarian columnist ever
anxious to take a sidekick at Boris
Johnson's government would find a way of
representing this pandemic as overhyped
and your columnist this hurts even to
type it may be wrong but so could others
so chuckling this Easter weekend as I
listened to the Archbishop of Canterbury
remind his flock of the eternal
Christian truths and values that Cove
aid 19 is bringing home to an anxious
nation I made a little list of other
familiar voices in our media respected
every one of them and rightly so but
very various in the opinions they
publish and each with his or her own
slant on a submicroscopic little virus
that any objective observer surely would
describe in the same way so I plug from
the error dozen or so names first I
thought let's guess how each will
recruit the corona virus pandemic to the
particular bees in each bonnet then
having guessed let's see what they
actually did say a word though first I'm
not implying any of them is wrong with
many I agree with all I sympathize we
each have our particular snakin we write
accordingly
I don't Marco okay maybe just a little
bit but I've mocked myself too and I
smile at the dexterity with which this
miserable pandemic can be bent to the
surface of so many conflicting opinions
now take Polly Toynbee Polly believes in
the power of the benevolent and
well-funded state Gradgrind
Tory government sir her bed noir as this
pandemic Peaks she writes the NHS and
Social Care are brutally worn down by a
decade of needless ideologically driven
austerity our stripped-down NHS will not
be able to cope but from the other side
the spectators Charles Moore sees the
NHS as an inefficient socialist monolith
as he believes Co bid 19 has proved the
inflexibility of our lumbering NHS he
writes in The Telegraph is why the
country has had to shut
back at the Guardian we're poly Toynbee
was writing George ma Bo whose
journalism is rooted in a belief that we
are wrecking our planet sees a clear
message written in the viruses death
statistics covet 19 is nature's wake-up
call to complacent civilization he
writes the papers Simon Jenkins however
here's a different wake-up call Simon
has been an excellent and tireless
champion of localism over the decades
his ears prick up as coronavirus strikes
we need local testing centers he writes
local food supplies local elderly care
local employment assistance above all
local leadership over at the Sunday
Telegraph Janet daily hears in wailing
ambulance sirens the call for a
different kind of leadership Boris will
be back
she writes we could give thanks for that
the mail on Sunday's Dan Hodges hears
the same call remember the caricature he
writes Boris was jeremy corbyn's
part-time PM and then the country saw
the reality a man who had worked himself
into the ground and then intensive care
in his attempt to keep britain safe the
mail on Sunday's Peter Hitchens draws a
different lesson from the far as his
spread as he laments the Johnson
government's stumbling retreat from
Reason interfere mr. Hitchens a tireless
advocate of individual liberty fears
this pandemic is hurting us towards a
police state my x colleagues are
absorbed in other matters attuned to
other messages from medical science
Ian Martin a strong advocate of brexit
concludes not without relish that
coronavirus could blow the EU apart
Philip Collins no fan of Labour's recent
expedition into insanity hopes it will
blow Corbin ism apart
mocking Corbin's supporters who are he
says so out of touch they believe covert
19 measures represent a victory for
their ideas
Janice Turner an admirable battler
against the trans lobby notices the
virus kills more men than women
how extraordinary that it took Ovid 19
she says to expose the absurdity of an
utterly unscientific argument that
biological sex is not real but an
artificial construct randomly assigned
to babies at birth
meanwhile the guardians are for hush
much of who's writing has been about the
roots and consequences of racism notices
disproportionate deaths in black
communities and wonders how come black
people are bearing the brunt but for the
broadcaster and writer Justin Webb a
hammer of one particular u.s.
presidential bid curve at 19 has a
different target in its sights step
forward he writes Joe Biden fill the
space calm the nerves
do it daily build something of substance
that's the challenge a low bar to be
cleared by a man or woman of any age but
he cannot do it David Miliband president
of the International Rescue Committee
and a campaigner for relief missions
sees a different challenge the world
won't be safe from coronavirus until
poor nations get more aid and finally to
our James Delingpole a writer I first
noticed 15 years ago in his wonderful
documentary about taking on the
hair-raising toboggan issed crest a run
in Switzerland a testament to the thrill
of being scared writing now about the
pandemic in de velde watcher James
laments the tragedy but what a time to
be alive he adds that was Matthew Paris
next Isabelle Hartman domestic abuse
sufferers are the hidden victims of the
lockdown by Isabel Hartman for years
ministers from successive governments
have conducted drills for all kinds of
pandemic scenarios but they never
imagined a lockdown it's a new tool and
its implications and side effects have
never been properly tested so no one
really thought about the effects it
would have on something like domestic
abuse before the lockdown it was
estimated that two women a week were
killed by their current or former
partners but
that was when they could move freely now
opportunities for escape a scarce the
only time a victim is alone is when
their abuser goes to the shop or if
they're allowed out for exercise the
abused women and they overwhelmingly are
women aren't going into work and so have
little chance to tell colleagues what's
going on or for anyone to spot signs of
physical violence this is another
opportunity for the men carrying out
these crimes they stand far less chance
of being found out an awful piece of
jargon in the domestic abuse world is
zoning it is when a perpetrator hits
their victim only on the parts of the
body that the rest of the world doesn't
see domestic abuse is carried out behind
closed doors and under clothes women
going to work looking perfectly normal
but with bruises and scars all over
their torsos a pattern horribly familiar
to those who work in shelters Michelle
Blum s'en who runs the East Surry
domestic abuse service tells me she has
spotted a shift in the type of abuse
perpetrators who haven't used physical
violence before they're starting to do
so now there's a worrying increase
around head and face injuries they're
not bothering to do zoning anymore
because no one is going to see the women
there are also now reports of children
being abused in a way that they were not
when school was still on pupils no
longer have a safe space to spend time
each day no one to talk to about what's
happening at home officially children
classed as vulnerable are entitled to go
to school in the lockdown but crucially
there is no obligation for them to do so
ministers had thought 20% of pupils
would keep coming less than 2% did so of
course only a small minority of children
exposed to abuse are recognized by
social workers as being at risk
blunt some and other charity workers
struggle to get through to women they
try to help in the lockdown because they
are rarely alone we know that survivors
really benefit from being directly asked
if they are being abused she says but
now no professional can directly ask
she tells her colleagues that if they
are talking to abused women they should
assume not only that the perpetrator is
there
but that the call is taking place on
speakerphone it's wrong to presume that
all domestic abuse is physical in recent
years there has been far wider
understanding of the emotional
techniques used in coercion constant
criticisms insults and screaming abuses
where their victim down so that the
victim comes to believe that they are as
useless as the person they love claims
they are and also importantly they come
to believe that their abuser is looking
after them a classic example of looking
after is controlling the household
finances to the point that the victim
has no agency of their own even to buy
basics like underwear or groceries which
also limits their ability to run away
huge advances have been made recently in
recognizing and tackling this Nicola
sharp Jeff's who runs the charity
surviving economic abuse says the
lockdown has given abusers an
opportunity to grow their system of
control there will be a number of women
who have lost their jobs or a furloughed
whose partners are using this as an
excuse to say we should be cutting back
on essentials like food clothing and
utilities to the extent that the money
they were saving to run away starts to
disappear police are doing their best to
respond to the rise in incidents
ministers are aware of the long term
cost of all this the longer the lockdown
goes on for the more cases there will be
and the harder it will be for specialist
services to help especially if their
funding dries up or their staff are
quarantined some two million pounds has
been announced for domestic abuse
helplines but this doesn't change the
current lack of options for victims once
they have found the courage and the
safety to Dahl those numbers women's
refuges have been oversubscribed for
years pre lockdown an average of around
90 women and the same number of children
were being turned away from these secure
properties every night because of lack
of space so what to do now
Priti Patel the Home Secretary has said
the government wants to keep victims in
their homes moving the perpetrators out
instead there will be enough
accommodation available she said but
those on the front line are skeptical
that this is really possible
Suzanne Jacob runs safe lives a charity
which often has the Home Office's Iran
abuse policy she worries about the end
of lockdown when women and children have
more freedom to tell others what's
happening and to try to escape this is
also the time when a woman is most
likely to be murdered
there will come a safeguarding peak when
all of the things that are being
suppressed behind closed doors will come
out there's this deep anxiety around
what level of service can really be
provided then other charities agree and
ask how they'll manage to pull qualified
domestic abuse workers out of thin air
but people are at least beginning to
notice this perhaps one of the very few
good things about this lockdown is a
greater awareness which might lead to
pressure on government to do more to
repair the damage when women currently
helped us seek help the surge in
government support for the NHS has shown
what can be done when the sense of
urgency is great enough perhaps it's not
too much to hope that when the worst of
kovat is over the indirect victims of
the crisis might warrant similar
attention that was Isabelle Hardman and
the day before this was published she
was challenging Matt Hancock about this
and the press conference although those
of you who have seen it will have
noticed that she wasn't particularly
good at giving answers anyway finally
Toby Young stinky malinki is growing on
me Toby Young since the beginning of the
lockdown caroline has been
congratulating herself for having bought
a puppy just in time she doesn't mean it
would have been impossible to get one
after the 23rd of March because visiting
a breeder is not an essential journey
she means that a puppy is a great source
of entertainment as well as solace when
you're cooped up in your home
particularly if you have children it's
like having our very own therapy dog
she's a cab a posh on a cross between a
Cavalier King Charles Spaniel a toy
poodle and a Bichon Frise a handbag dog
in other words we had an interminable
family discussion about what to name her
with the children seemingly engaged in a
competition to
up with the most cliched suggestions our
eldest son notionally the owner of the
dog wanted to call her biscuit or
failing that cookie our 16 year old
daughter wanted to call her Cali
short for Calypso why not just call her
cherry and have done with it I said the
eleven-year-old suggested ecco but
thankfully that was ruled out when we
discovered another cab a pooch on owner
a trendy young man who lives nearby had
named his echo he glides along the
pavement on his man scooter with echo
peeping out from a Papoose tied to his
front past the sick bag in the end we
plumped for malinki which means tiny in
check Caroline likes it because she's
half Czech and I like it because it
means I can call the dog
stinky malinki as the person who has to
clear up her messes I've begun to
suspect that the poo in her breed name
is not a reference to poodle but to
something else she's like a little
factory capable of manufacturing her
body weight in the stuff every 24 hours
the downside of the name malinki is that
the children have shortened it to Marlee
which if pronounced with a long a is a
slang term for a Somalian for that
reason shouting Marlee at the top of
your lungs in Acton Park during your
once a day exercise can be hazardous I'm
constantly hissing at them to pronounce
it with a short a like most little dogs
malinki has a habit of running up to big
dogs and barking at them I worry they
might eat her ooh
Scooby Snack but she seems to be aware
of the danger because as soon as they
take any notice she immediately rolls
over and sticks her paws in the air even
though it's disappointing to see her
surrender so quickly I dare say it's
sensible for a brief period in New York
I was the owner of a Yorkshire Terrier
named Jack he was originally my
girlfriend's dog but I got custody when
we broke up
I loved Jack because he was always
picking fight with bigger dogs and he
never backed down like some pocket-sized
Irish brawler but in the end it was his
undoing I found a new home for him on a
farm up
and on the first day he was there he bit
their Border Collie she was a
battle-hardened working dog not some
namby-pamby city dog that was the end of
Jack one of the drawbacks of having a
dog during this crisis is that they
don't stick to the 2 meter rule when
you're outside the home
in the park Carolyn and I will
scrupulously observe social distancing
etiquette crossing to the other side of
the path whenever we see someone coming
towards us
but Manny runs up to everyone within a
hundred-yard radius and begins jumping
up and trying to lick them inevitably
they start stroking her what an adorable
little thing and I worried that if
they've got corona germs on their hands
they'll transfer them to her and she
will then transfer them to us
who knows dogs could be super spreaders
the reason the death toll is so high in
spite of the lockdown
whenever I complain about this Caroline
reminds me that I claim to have had the
virus so what am I worried about well
yes probably but even so I was the most
reluctant member of our household when
it came to getting a new pet having not
enjoyed owning our previous dog leo was
a Hungarian Vizsla and we had to rehouse
him when he bit an Accardo delivery man
and Caroline received a police caution
but Malley is growing on me she has such
a sweet trusting little face it's hard
not to warm to her and in truth
watching her become part of the family
has made the lockdown more bearable if
only she didn't poo quite so much that
was Toby Young and that's the end of our
audio selection this week please do send
us an email on podcasts a spectator code
at UK to let us know what you think of
this the format we've only done it for
two or three weeks so anybody you'd like
to include on our next issue and please
do let us know either in an email or you
can leave a message under the YouTube
screen if you're listening to this on
YouTube our issue next week by the way
is rather a special one it's our
10,000th issue no magazine in the
history of publishing in this or any
other country
has come up with a 10,000 issue and
we've got something pretty special to
show you so for those of you who
subscribe to the magazine look out for
it for those of you who would have
bought the magazine then bidets where
there are shops to sell it what can I
say except you know you can buy it
online or maybe the supermarket that was
seller or something is pretty good so do
look out for it and also while while I'm
here thank you to you our subscribers
thank you to our listeners thank you to
our readers for giving us this success
and this longevity it's pretty difficult
times to the press right now but the
spectator is celebrating not just a
record number of issues but a record
number of readers so from us to you
thank you